heute live herzlich willkommen die
vierte welle hat uns erfasst die korona
zahlen gehen durch die decke und wir
fragen uns wie schlimm ist denn die lage
tatsächlich was planen die ampel
parteien in berlin und ist das alles
medizinisch sinnvoll und b auch
rechtlich zulässig darüber diskutieren
wir gerne mit euch und außerdem mit den
folgenden beiden gästen zum einen mit
unserer sehr geschätzten zdf kollegin
sarah attacke leiterin der redaktion
recht und justiz die uns hier im studio
besucht einen schönen guten abend schön
dass du da bist frei und wir erreichen
mit dem virologen martin stürmer auch er
vielfacher gast unserer sendung und
zugeschaltet aus dem schönen landkreis
offenbar und abends herthas stürmer
nahm zusammen ja und bevor wir in die
diskussion einsteigen wollen wir alle
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer noch mal
schnell mit ein paar infos darüber
versorgen wie sich die lage die krone
lage heute in deutschland darstellt
zwei tage vor heiligabend gab es den
bisherigen höchstwert
197,6 jetzt ein neuer unschöner rekord
wie kann das sein zumal damals noch
niemand geimpft war jetzt sind es gut 67
prozent vollständig und
85,5 prozent der gefährdeten über 60
jährigen allerdings geht es mit dem
impfen kaum voran zugleich wurde das
virus mit der delta variante noch
ansteckender folge vor allem ungeimpfte
stecken sich seit herbst anfangen wieder
mehr an hier die 18 bis 59 jährigen
geimpfte infizieren sich auch aber
weitaus weniger
vergleichbar sind die entwicklungen bei
den über 60 jährigen
entsprechend kommen auch aus dieser
altersgruppe deutlich mehr ungeimpfte
ins krankenhaus als geimpfte viele
ungeimpfte viele auch die ohne symptome
sind und das virus verbreiten all das
erklärungen für die vielen
neuinfektionen und argumente für
verstärktes impfen postern und
testen
ja und wie immer gilt natürlich eure
fragen und kommentare gerne an uns wir
fangen wir an mit dem virologen
hersteller rekordwerte also bei den
instanzen werden es gerade im beitrag
gesehen logischerweise aber gibt es auch
viel mehr geimpfte als noch im letzten
herbst weil klar die impfung haben ja
erst begonnen wie dramatisch ist denn
die lage nun tatsächlich aus ihrer sicht
ja es ist schon eine sehr sehr
spannend spannende situation stand
insofern dass wir noch nicht genau
wissen wo es hingehen wird es ist zu
befürchten dass die intensivstation und
krankenhäuser weiter belastet werden
also über das hinaus was wir jetzt schon
sehen weil das kennen wir ja aus der
vergangenen wellen dass die
infektionszahlen und die die
intensivbetten belebung nicht ganz
zeitnah
einhergehen natürlich durch die impfung
ist ist diese korrelation wie wir sie im
letzten herbst haben etwas abgemildert
was aber nicht heißt dass wir überhaupt
keine menschen mehr eben corona
assoziiert in die krankenhäuser bekommen
das thema ja aktuell schon insofern muss
man sich schon ein bisschen sorgen
machen was das ganze angeht und wirklich
schauen dass wir dieses
infektionsgeschehen jetzt wirklich
schnell wieder in den griff bekommen
sind sie eigentlich überrascht von den
hohen zahlen
nein das war etwas was zu befürchten war
was auch vielfach nicht nur von mir
sondern auch von vielen kolleginnen und
kollegen immer wieder vorhergesagt
worden ist achtung wir haben eine delta
variante wir bekommen die kalte
jahreszeit
es wird naturgemäß einfach von länder
von den fallzahlen steigen was dazu
kommt dass ein sehr starker
lockerungskurs
eingeschlagen worden ist der das ganze
letztendlich zusätzlich befeuert hat
jetzt stehen wir da jetzt müssen wir
schauen wie wir da wieder rauskommen
ja das ist interessant oder in der tat
die interessante frage wie kommen wir da
wieder raus sarah du bewertet die kohle
rohner lage heute für uns juristisch wie
gut gehen seiner einschätzung nach mit
dieser situation mit überhaupt diese
herausforderung corona pandemie oben
rechtlich gesehen also rechtlich gesehen
muss man sagen so gut wir können das
problem ist natürlich das virus dem oder
dem virus ist es völlig egal was wir
juristisch was wir politisch machen
umgekehrt ist es aber für juristisches
und politisches handeln ganz
entscheidend was das virus macht und da
lernen wir immer noch dazu das heißt wir
können immer nur das virus oder auf das
virus reagieren mit dem wissensstand den
wir aktuell haben dass der sich aber
auch immer wieder ändert müssen wir auch
die juristischen maßnahmen das
politische handeln immer wieder anpassen
dh
soweit ich das beobachte versuchen
sowohl politiker als auch juristen
angemessene adäquate maßnahmen zu
ergreifen allerdings hat die
vergangenheit gezeigt dass diese
maßnahme manchmal zu tiefgreifend sind
manchmal zu zögerlich manchmal zu
schnell gekommen und unüberlegt sind
oder manchmal auch zu spät kommen das
heißt ich würde sagen insgesamt so gut
wir können aber das ist natürlich nicht
immer gut genug ja es ist jedenfalls ein
ständiges austarieren wir nehmen gerne
schon mal einen user kommentaren mit
rein pascal rocken stillstands über
youtube man muss jetzt abwägen zwischen
dem einschränken der rechte von personen
und dem möglichen retten von leben dabei
sollte man im hinterkopf behalten dass
bei beiden maßnahmen hauptsächlich nur
diejenigen betroffen sind die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen deshalb bin ich für
keine weiteren maßnahmen mit ausnahme
der masken pflicht für alle in
geschlossenen räumen so seine meinung
wie gesagt gerne mehr noch davon die
ansage an alle von euch uns gerne eure
fragen und kommentare zu schicken also
auch die ampel parteien in berlin die
wissen natürlich auch um den ernst der
lage heute haben die künftigen
koalitionspartner aller voraussicht nach
spd grüne und fdp einen gesetzesentwurf
mit gegenmaßnahmen auf den weg gebracht
und dazu sehen jetzt noch mal ein paar
einzelheiten und an lage spitzt sich zu
doch die möglichen ampelkoalition ehre
wollen die sogenannte epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite ende november
auslaufen lassen stattdessen bringen sie
neue gesetzliche leitplanken auf den weg
für die fdp ein notwendiger schritt weg
vom ausnahmezustand aber nicht das ende
aller maßnahmen
niemand hat behauptet dass corona vorbei
sein aber die angemessenen instrumente
die wir noch brauchen die eben
verhältnismäßig sind die sinnvoll sind
und zweckmäßig sind stellen wir auf eine
neue rechtsgrundlage
in der diskussion von spd grünen und fdp
die kostenlosen tests wieder einzuführen
auch eine testpflicht in pflegeheimen
ärzte sollen strikt dazu nach impfungen
informieren und die 3g regel soll am
arbeitsplatz gelten flächendeckende
schließung von schulen handel oder
kultur soll es nicht mehr geben doch die
bundesländer sollen weiter corona
maßnahmen wie masken tragen anordnen
können
sie haben bis zum 24 november noch alle
möglichkeiten die die bestätigung der
pandemischen lage letztlich ihnen gibt
aber sie werden auch möglichkeiten haben
in zukunft dann mit einem dann
hoffentlich beschlossenen
infektionsschutzgesetz ausreichend zu
arbeiten nicht einigen konnten sich die
potenziellen koalitionäre auf eine
bundesweite zweig regel die vieles nur
geimpften und genießen gestattet in
pflegeheimen soll strenger getestet
werden eine impfpflicht soll es dort
zunächst nicht geben auch aus sorge dass
dann noch mehr personal abspringt ich
würde jedenfalls für dramatisch reichen
camp in der lage haben wo jemand sagt
bevor ich mich impfen dass er aber ich
da lieber nicht mehr und das ist eine
erwägung an der ich jedenfalls nicht
vorbei will aber ich möchte gern dass
wir durch sicherheit haben an diesem
donnerstag sollen die ideen der ampel
bereits in erster lesung im bundestag
beraten werden
also da gibt es einige aspekte die wir
natürlich schön der reihe nach
medizinisch und juristisch abklopfen
wollen wir fangen mal an herr stürmer
also 2g oder 3g
das ist jetzt beides vorgekommen in
diesen beitrag in unterschiedlichen
zusammenhängen vielleicht kann man da
noch mal ein bisschen ordnung
reinbringen wann es denn aus
medizinischer sicht welche
vorgehensweise sind voll wann braucht es
zwei gebern braucht es drei wie kann man
das so pauschal sagen
ich glaube so pauschal kann man das
schwer einen einsetzen oder oder
zuordnen es gibt für beide beide systeme
so ein bisschen vor und nachteile wenn
wir jetzt mal uns die 3g regel vornehmen
die klassische dann ist es ja so dass
wir ein misch eine mischung haben
ausgelesenen geimpften und eben
entsprechenden
getesteten personen
hier ist es so dass gerade wenn man den
test auf pc r basis stellen also die
sogenannte 3g plus geht von denen
natürlich eine relativ geringe
infektionsgefahr raus anders als bei
genesenen geimpften wo er doch der eine
oder andere vielleicht hilft durchbruch
hat der nicht erkannt wird aber es kann
natürlich eben in dieser konstellation
durchaus zu infektionsketten kommen mit
einer relativ großen wahrscheinlichkeit
insofern ist 3g da ein bisschen
benachteiligt weil ich eben größere
ausbruchsgeschehen provozieren kann die
sich dann auch eben weiter fortsetzen
eine strikte zweige regelung vermeidet
das weil ich eben keine überträger drin
habe aber wir haben gesehen dass auch
zweig konzepte nicht nur 100 prozentige
sicherheit
gewährleisten jeder mensch ist anders
jedes immunsystem ist unterschiedlich
gut und schlecht und eben kann es auch
zu unter zweig situation zu ausbrüchen
kommen deswegen kann man sich einer
meinung nach auch nicht alleine auf ein
zweig konzept stützen wir haben ein
bisschen aus dem auge verloren das in
der aktuellen infektions lage die wir
haben sehr viele infektionen stattfinden
es eben auch häufiger zu impft
durchbrüchen kommt weil viele impfungen
auch entsprechend länger zurückliegen
das müssen wir berücksichtigen dass
unser test konzept da nochmal schärfen
und wenn wir das in verbindung mit
vernünftigen zugangsbeschränkungen in
öffentlichen veranstaltungen oder in
restaurants oder diskotheken
wenn wir das kombinieren dann haben wir
eine chance kontakte einfach sicherer zu
machen weil ich befürchte das sei an dem
beitrag auch angeklungen dass wir nicht
wieder zurückgehen werden auf klassische
mechanismen die wir aus dem letzten jahr
kennen ja also zwei oder 3g modelle sie
sagen beides hat vor und nachteile sager
die rede ist ja konkret auch von 3g am
arbeitsplatz also das ist ein punkt der
jetzt auf taucht in dem papier der
ampelkoalition ehre welche welche
rechtlichen aspekte sind da zu beachten
beim thema 3g oder ja ja also bei 2g ist
ganz klar dass das nur möglich ist bei
dingen die nicht also man nett ist
daseinsfürsorge also die nicht elementar
sind also man kann nicht ungeimpfte
davon ausschließen dass sie im
supermarkt gehen als sie müssen
weiterhin lebensmittel einkaufen können
man kann ungeimpfte auch nicht also
jetzt juristisch gesehen also
verhältnismäßig ist es nicht
verhältnismäßig ungeimpfte davon
auszuschließen dass sie die bahn
benutzen das sehe ich nicht das sind
eingriffe die dazu weitreichend sind
ansonsten finde ich grundsätzlich bei
dieser 2g 3g also
diskussion
wird zu wenig darauf geschaut wie
gefährlich eigentlich ein ungeimpfter
ist er aber getestet ist das natürlich
die frage ist es der schnelltest ist der
schnelltest den jemand gemacht hat der
das professionell macht ist dass hier
schnell ist ein pc welche form von test
welche form von sicherheit habe ich da
aber auch da ist die frage ist das nicht
also ist nicht ein ungeübter aber unter
aufsicht oder von professionellen
kräften getesteter nicht vielleicht
sogar ungefährlicher oder aber
mindestens nicht gefährlicher als ein
gamestar aktuell wir sehen ja die vielen
impf durch brücke gleich können wir die
freiheit weitergeben an dem experten wie
sehen sie das
ja das ist eine argumentation die die
wir häufiger eben auch diskutieren und
und die natürlich ganz berechtigt ist
diese frage zu stellen bin ich nicht als
ungeimpfte aber getesteter weniger
gefährlich für andere man muss es von
zwei seiten sehen auf der einen seite ja
ist es richtig wenn das an ordentlich
durchgeführter test ist wenn ich für
diesen zeitraum in dieser veranstaltung
sicher dass ich nicht andere anstecken
aber ich bin natürlich in einem kontext
je nachdem wie das ganze gestaltet ist
ein möglicher virus
empfänger der also eine infektion
bekommen und dann entsprechend wieder
unbemerkt an andere weitergeben kann und
da liegt meiner meinung nach die große
gefahr der der 3g konzepte dass er eben
ein größeres potenzial haben
infektionsketten zu generieren also die
weitergabe des virus damit noch
beschleunigen können und da sehe ich die
gefahr
ist es nur juristisch so man kann
grundrechte nur einschränken wenn
derjenige der da eingeschränkt wird mir
gefahr für andere darstellt also mann
kann sie nicht einschränken weil man
sagt wir machen jetzt eine impfpflicht
schlicht aus dem grund dass das du nicht
krank werden sollte er es geht immer
darum man kann diese freiheitsrechte
jemand nehmen denn eine gefahr für
andere also man kann jemanden nicht vor
sich selbst schützen sozusagen genau
genau er sondern nur und da ist
entscheidend wie hoch also wie hoch
diese gefahr vor anderen und deswegen
finde ich in dieser diskussion ob es
verhältnismäßig ist flächendeckend
einzuführen das nur noch geimpfte und
genießen in der kneipe gehen können also
bestimmt an freizeit veranstaltung
teilnehmen können da kommt wirklich zu
kurz ob es nicht und da sind wir im
juristischen verhältnismäßiger ist weil
es ein milderes mittel ist das genauso
wirksam ist vielleicht sogar wirksamer
ist ein einen ungeimpften nimmt bestimmt
test vorzuschreiben ob das jetzt ein gt
r testet so dann schnell dass es da sind
wir wieder auf die virologen angewiesen
die sagen dass es dann gleichwertig oder
sogar sicherer ich finde es nur
schwierig wie aktuell einfach
flächendeckend zweig regeln also
eingeführt werden ohne darauf zu schauen
ob man nicht da ungeimpfte
unverhältnismäßig benachteiligt team-em
schreibt uns über youtube ist es
rechtlich wirklich erlaubt dass die
allgemeinheit dauerhaft die kosten der
tests in vollem umfang für diejenigen
übernimmt die sich infizieren oder
überhaupt für eigentlich alle die sich
testen lassen wollen ich meine das ist
natürlich auch ein punkte jetzt in der
letzten zeit häufig diskutiert worden
ist da kann ich gleich noch mal die
meinung des experten vielleicht so
abfragen aber vielleicht erstmal die
juristische frage wie ist das zu
bewerten dies ist vor allem eine
politische frage also erstmal so
grundsätzlichen ja allgemein hat wollen
wir diese kosten tragen oder wollen wir
das nicht also und da ist die frage
macht es das ganze sicherer oder nicht
es wird juristisch wenn zum beispiel ein
arbeitgeber vorschreibt dass nur
getestete ungeimpfte noch zur arbeit
kommen dürfen weil dann da sind wir
wieder bei meinem supermarkt beispiel
beim deutschen bahn beispiel da werde
ich dann ausgeschlossen davon wenn ich
nicht adäquaten anderen job machen kann
von von von meiner arbeit zu leben also
werde von meinem job ausgeschlossen da
wird es wieder juristisch und da gehe
ich davon aus anders als es
beispielsweise in italien ist das das da
kostenlose zur verfügung gestellt werden
müssen aber ansonsten ist es eine rein
politische frage was wir wollen ja
fragen wir nochmal nach beim mediziner
inwieweit ist das flächendeckende testen
das wird auch von kollegen von ihnen ja
immer wieder ins spiel gebracht ein ganz
wichtiges instrument um eben die dynamik
auch der pandemie zu verstehen und
vielleicht auch dann rechtzeitig
gegenzusteuern
ja natürlich ist das ein ganz
elementarer baustein der wir nicht außer
acht lassen dürfen weil jeden den ich
positiv teste dem kann ich halt eben
auch gemäß der gesetzeslage
infektionsschutzgesetz sagen okay da
musst du jetzt sich aus dem öffentlichen
leben zurückziehen und gewährleistet
damit dass es eben nicht zur weitergabe
des virus kommt und das ist ja der
elementarer punkt um den ist
letztendlich geht infektionsketten zu
durchbrechen und das kann ich nicht wenn
ich nicht testen wenn ich kein positives
ergebnis habe
vielen dank sarah inwieweit können tests
verpflichtend gemacht werden das ist ja
jetzt vermeintlich gesehen eher geringer
eingriff in meine rechte wenn ich mich
jetzt testen das muss im unterschied
vielleicht zu einer impfung da können
wir gleich auch noch drüber sprechen und
da kommt auch wieder darauf an also man
also es kann verpflichtend sein wenn ich
sage zb in meinem restaurant kommen das
kann ich auch privat entscheiden in
meinem restaurant kommen nur geimpfte
genesene und getestete und mich frei
meine entscheidung und da muss derjenige
in dem die nicht nur ein das aber dann
test machten sich auch selber darum
kümmern dass er den hut dann sind wir
wieder bei dem durchaus weitaus
kritischere beim arbeitsplatz und auch
da ist es möglich tests vorschreiben und
auch da müssen wir wieder an der an der
verhältnismäßigkeit wann ist ein
eingriff weil es am ende schon auch ein
eingriff wann ist dieser gerechtfertigt
und da kann man sagen dass in den
besonders sensiblen bereichen wie
beispielsweise pflegen und altenheime wo
ich ungetestet wirklich eine katastrophe
auslösen kann oder aber auch kitas und
schulen das sind bereiche wo eine
testpflicht sicherlich möglich ist
und wo vermutlich auch eine impfpflicht
möglich wäre meiner einschätzung nach da
kommen wir gleich drauf felix körber
schreibt uns über youtube bei uns in
sachsen schließen ja allerdings schon
wieder die clubs auch für geimpfte das
finde ich ein auch nicht fair das so
einfach mal ein statement jetzt von ihm
maximal über facebook wenn die
intensivstationen irgendwann tatsächlich
überlastet sind wäre es rechtlich
zulässig
patienten mit impft durchbrüchen
vorzuziehen gegenüber ungeimpften
personen wie es das
gibt es ja eine unterschiedlich sehen so
ist das aus dem bauch heraus wir haben
aber aber aber nein also das kann man
nicht machen das also würde glaube ich
auch jeder also kein arzt machen dass
man immer auf dem neuesten stand sondern
also ich bin jetzt keine medizinerin
aber ich gehe ich schwer davon aus dass
ein arzt schaut welcher patient braucht
welche versorgung und danach wird
entschieden ja wie gesagt dass eine user
frage habe ich habe auch glaube ich hier
einen kopfschütteln bei herrn stürmer 1
einnicken ich höre ich glaube also ja
wickeln zu deinem ausführungen aber
einen kopf stellen was sie fragen
also das wird nicht gemacht wird nicht
unterschieden genau ja gut nein das ist
jetzt wird rein medizinische aspekte ja
genau also da keine unterschiede sarah
wie sieht es mit der impfung aus dass es
gerade schon angesprochen wenn wir uns
um gucken in frankreich zum beispiel da
gibt es ja in einigen bereichen eine
impfpflicht zum beispiel im
gesundheitswesen ich glaube auch bei der
feuerwehr
gerade haben wir gehört ist könnte eher
abschreckende wirkung haben das war auch
teil des beitrags weil man befürchtet
dass manche leute dann nicht mehr zur
arbeit kommen wollen gerade in
pflegeeinrichtungen oder so das ist
jetzt kein juristischer hinderungsgrund
deine einschätzung nach wäre also eine
impfpflicht machbar habe ich jetzt wird
schon was genau
sein also kommt darauf an für wen
und am ende ist das also eine prognose
die die ich hier aktive ich also ich
weiss es am ende auch nicht künstlich
müsste dem klassischen
verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip bestand
halten und natürlich das ist das also
legitimes ziel das dass man keine
anderen gefährdet durch eine impfung
hakelig wird es bei der frage ob das
ganze erforderlich ist also ob es nicht
ein milderes mittel gibt da sind wir
wieder beim testen also und der frage ob
nicht ein
meinetwegen auch ptr oder oder
professionell getestet da nicht
vielleicht sogar
genauso wenig infektiös ansteckend ist
wie ein
kind geimpft und dass das ist die
entscheidende frage weil also dieser hat
dieser grundrechtseingriff impfung also
jemanden impfung vorzuschreiben der ist
so massiv dass man vorher schamlos gibt
es nicht mildere mittel mit denen man
genauso gut zum ziel kommen kann und da
sind wir wieder bei den virologen auf
die wir angewiesen sind oder eben logan
weil nur die das beantworten können ja
aber das ganz praktisch wir haben ja
einen heer
stürmer also wie sieht es aus mit der
impfpflicht aus fachlicher sicht wäre
das wahrscheinlich für sie wünschenswert
oder wie wie schätzen sie das ein
natürlich ist jeder mensch der
zusätzlich jetzt geimpft wird ein
schritt weiter um letztendlich die
pandemien irgendeiner form in den griff
zu bekommen ich denke da sind uns einig
dass letztendlich wenn wir uns alle
durch hätten impfen lassen dass wir über
solche zahlen und solche situationen gar
nicht reden würden dementsprechend ist
je nachdem er zusätzlich bekommen immer
sehr sehr wertvolle ob der weg jetzt
sehr wichtige ist klar kann man darüber
streiten wenn wir wirklich gute test
prinzipien etablieren können dann bin
ich der meinung dass wir diese
impfpflicht nicht unbedingt wirklich
brauchen weil ich glaube auch dass es
gerade viele leute auch abschreckt davor
das durchzuziehen ja mit dem betrieb der
eher sagen denn dann schreibe ich mich
krank bevor ich mich jetzt impfen lass
muss uns zur arbeit gehe und entspricht
unser pflegesystem unser
gesundheitssystem zusammen um es
überspitzt zu formulieren
ich denke eine gesunde abwägung zu
versuchen wirklich mehr menschen zu
motivieren hier nochmal mit
aufklärungskampagnen wirklich auch an
das verantwortungsbewusstsein der
entsprechenden person für ihre patienten
diese betreuen zu appellieren das ist
sicherlich ganz wichtig und dann halt
eben adäquate testung in den halt in den
einrichtungen etablieren um die
sicherheit deutlich zu erhöhen das sind
sicherlich die aspekte zweigleisig daran
kann man sollte also eine zweigleisige
lösung wird vorgeschlagen sache genauso
wenn man das wenn man das mal
durchspielt jetzt wir haben es gerade
gehört 67 prozent der erwachsenen sind
geimpft wenn wir da jetzt bei
traumhaften 100 prozent werden wir
hatten ja trotzdem impf durchbrüche wer
die situation dann gut beherrschbar oder
ist diese delta variante so aggressiv
dass wir selbst durch eine also also
dass wir nie eine herdenimmunität
herstellen können
also wir werden über kurz oder lang
einfach lernen müssen mit dem virus zu
leben in welcher form wir das machen das
wird sicherlich über kurz oder lang in
die normalität zurückkehren weil wir
müssen mit vielen infektionskrankheiten
leben und haben vor ohne auch nicht
jedes jeden winter und im herbst uns die
masken aufgesetzt um uns in die
quarantäne begeben die in die isolation
begeben
insofern wenn wir uns alle impfen lassen
können dann muss man mit einem
restrisiko leben das ist eben
tatsächlich noch einzelne infektionen
gibt nur sie wird nicht in dem maße
durchlaufen wenn wir jetzt alle geimpft
sind ist die wahrscheinlichkeit selber
sich anzustecken das virus weiter zu
geben an giften deutlich geringer als
das was wir jetzt sehen das ist zwar
auch immer sind immer durchbrüche dabei
aber es sind tatsächlich in der mehrzahl
ungeimpfte die aktuell krank werden und
es davon auszugehen dass das auch die
mehrheit bleiben wird insofern werden
wir da doch eine gehörige portion an
infektionen aus diesem system entfernen
und würden nicht über eine pandemische
ausmaße reden sondern über einzelne
aufflackernde infektionsherde in
deutschland
herrscht immer ich lese gerade noch eine
zuschrift von gisele dickmann menschen
aufspalten in geimpft und ungeimpft ist
hetze inzwischen sind zu viele vom im
versagen euphemistisch impf durchbrüche
betroffen also einer ziemlich muss man
jetzt sagen polemische äußerungen vor
einem jahr waren die zahlen zur
erkrankungen todesfällen intensiv
bettenbelegung niedriger ohne impfung
heute mit impfung sind die zahlen höher
vielleicht können sie das nochmal weil
ich glaube das ist ein reflex oder auch
eine haltung die bei vielen bei uns auch
vor herrscht vielleicht können sie das
noch mal ein ort wie ist das zu
begründen
ja also ist natürlich nicht so dass
jetzt mehr menschen auf den fünf
stationen legen weil wir impfen dass
diese korrelation die muss man sich mal
schnell nicht aus dem kopf schlagen wir
hatten ganz andere situationen wenn wir
das nicht täten wir haben eine variante
die wir letztes jahr im herbst nicht
hatten die ist deutlich aggressiver in
der verbreitung die stellt uns vor ganz
andere herausforderungen wir haben
inzwischen die die maßnahmen soweit
zurückgefahren dass wir vieles erlauben
delta nutzt jegliche chance aus sich
entsprechend zu verbreiten und wird ohne
impfen würde das ganze viel viel
katastrophaler aussehen werden noch ganz
andere zahlen die deutlich höher werden
und die intensivstationen werden jetzt
schon komplett überlaufen insofern ist
das impfen jetzt absolut der richtige
weg die impf durchbrüche ja mit denen
müssen wir leben in den haben aber auch
gerechnet die kennen wir von anderen
impfungen auch keine impfung bis 100
prozent perfekt aber das reduziert für
mich persönlich das risiko schwer krank
zu werden oder gar zu versterben das
risiko longo wird zu bekommen wird
reduziert und ich reduziere für andere
das risiko weil die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sich das virus weiter gebe an
andere geimpft oder umkämpfte ist
deutlich geringer und wenn ich mit nur
mit geimpften in einem raum denn deine
infektionskette zu erzeugen das ist
schon ein relativ seltenes ereignis ich
verstehe
entscheidend für viele maßnahmen in den
letzten monaten war das
infektionsschutzgesetz auch ein
herrlicher verächtlicher der - und darin
geregelt auch die sogenannte epidemische
lage was es damit genau auf sich hat und
was daraus jetzt folgen wird dazu jetzt
noch ein paar einzelheiten
wir sind jetzt in einem zustand
besonderer vorsicht wo auch bestimmte
schutzmaßnahmen weiterhin gelten und
gleichzeitig können wir jedenfalls den
ausnahmezustand wo der bundesminister
für gesundheit etwa durch verordnungen
viele viele ausnahmeregelungen treffen
kann diesen zustand braucht es eben
nicht mehr und dann finde ich ihnen
wichtig ein ausnahmezustand wo per
verordnung regiert werden kann dann auch
zu beenden was der
bundesgesundheitsminister schon im
oktober forderte wollen jetzt auch spd
grüne und fdp auslaufen lassen
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite
sie steht in paragraf 5 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und wird vom
bundestag festgestellt wenn eine
ernsthafte gefahr für die öffentliche
gesundheit in der gesamten
bundesrepublik deutschland besteht sie
ist voraussetzung für konkrete maßnahmen
die meistens von den landesregierungen
per verordnung bestimmt wurden dazu
gehörten unter anderem abstandsgebot
masten pflicht betriebsschließung und
ausgangs beschränkungen die pandemische
lage wurde vom bundestag im märz 2020
beschlossen und immer wieder verlängert
am 25 november läuft sie aus dafür
sollen andere regelungen ins
infektionsschutzgesetz aber was ändert
sich dadurch konkret
ja das scheint meine frage zu sein für
unsere rechtsexperte also gewisse
geschickt weiter was ändert sich konkret
entscheidend ist dass die länder weiter
verordnung erlassen können und dass es
weiter möglich ist 3g 2g zweig + 3g plus
in welcher form auch immer
vorzuschreiben dass nur geimpfte
genesene ungeimpfte getestete mit pcr
test an bestimmten
restaurantbesuchen et cetera teilnehmen
entscheidend ist aber auch dass dieser
maßnahmenkatalog aus denen die länder
vorher schätzen konnten der hatte 17
punkte meines wissens § 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz der wir das
reduziert auf schlanke sechs punkte und
die ganz tief greifenden maßnahmen die
fallen raus also es wird keine also wenn
das jetzt gesetzt wird es wird keine
flächendeckenden schulschließungen mehr
geben es wird keine ausgangs
beschränkungen mehr geben können und
keine kontakt beschränkungen mehr geben
können also das sind jetzt mal so den
drei großen tiefgreifenden maßnahmen
das heißt die botschaft ist vor allem ja
die länder werden weiter wie aktuell
sowieso auch schon auf die
infektionszahlen reagieren es gibt
weiterhin die die bundes möglichkeit das
zu tun und jedes land entscheidet wie
aktuell auch was es tun will es ist nur
so dass die länder nicht mehr aus den
vollen schöpfen können sie können nicht
mehr ganz tief in unsere grundrechte
eingreifen da sind sie beschränkt worden
aber natürlich kann jederzeit wieder der
bundestag zusammentreten das ist eine
ermessensentscheidung sagen wir haben
diese epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite und dann kann man das ganze
wieder aufleben lassen das heißt er kann
reagiert werden und es für mich als
bürger bis zu dem punkt dass ich nicht
mehr damit rechnen dass die schule
schließt oder ich in meinen kontakten
beschränkt werde oder nicht mehr alle
ausgehen darf mich nicht mehr frei
bewegen darf
wird es weitermachen pflicht geben und
und weitere maßnahmen was sagt denn der
virologe zu dieser entwicklung oft ist
es ja so fest der jurist aufatmet dann
zieht sich beim mediziner zusammen und
auch andersrum also haben sie jetzt
sorge dass die künftigen maßnahmen dann
zu lasch sein könnten
ja es ist natürlich
interessanter punkt der jetzt
aufgegriffen wird ich habe mich gefragt
warum im oktober wo ist ja schon
absehbar war dass die zahlen steigen
werden dass die intensivstation wieder
stärker belastet werden dass wir uns dem
ganzen thema der belastung und
überlastung wieder nähern das dann schon
vorgriff gesagt wurde das können wir
ohne probleme beenden ich sag immer
warum soll man ein funktionierendes
system ändern wenn ich doch mehr damit
maßnahmen wegnehme die ich dann
vielleicht doch wieder brauchen könnte
das heißt ja nicht was die
infektionsschutzgesetz das verstehen die
maßnahmen das heißt ja nicht dass man
die anwenden muss wenn ich sie jetzt
aber abstellen dann kann ich sie erst
mal nicht wieder anwenden bis vielleicht
wieder die lage neu beschlossen wird
aber dann kann es auch zu spät sein
glaubt keiner von uns möchte wieder ein
locker und schulschließungen und
sonstwas haben das möchte ich genauso
wenig ich bin auch der meinung dass wir
die situation auch ohne diese maßnahmen
in den griff bekommen können ich
verstehe noch nicht den hintergrund
warum man jetzt sagt gerade wo es eben
wieder eng wird und wo wir uns wieder
einem kritischen zustand nähern dass man
mit dieser diskussion meiner meinung
nach jetzt auch falsches signal gesetzt
und dann vielleicht eben auch da gewisse
begehrlichkeiten weckt die wir
vielleicht nicht wecken sollten ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass das ganze im
frühjahr stattfindet weil da halte ich
es auch definitiv waren messen stichwort
falsches signal sarah absolut ich möchte
ihnen zu hundert prozent zustimmen weil
ich das ganz genauso sehe es also wieso
jetzt es macht überhaupt gar keinen sinn
und was die epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite angelangt ist legaldefinition
definiert in § 5 infektionsschutzgesetz
und die sieht vor dass das
gesundheitssystem überfordert ist an
seine grenzen kommt und genau die
situation haben wir nichtsdestotrotz
steht es den abgeordneten bundestag frei
zu entscheiden haben wir diese lag oder
haben wir sie nicht und selbst wenn man
die jetzt auslaufen lässt also nicht
verlängert heißt das nicht dass sich für
mich praktisch was ändert also das ist
das was ich sagen will also abgesehen
davon dass die besonders scharfen
maßnahmen nicht mehr ergriffen werden
können wir können weiterhin gibt es ein
maßnahmenkatalog inwieweit auf diese
koran corinna lage reagiert werden kann
ich finde es nicht richtig ehrlich
gesagt
dass jetzt zu machen es ist es völlig
widersinnig wieso die zahlen geben es
nicht her also wenn man hätte das im
sommer hätte man beenden können weil
umgekehrt muss man auch sagen was daran
hängt und was auch der
gesundheitsminister gesagt hat ist
natürlich eine machtverschiebung also
macht weg von den parlamenten hin zu
einer regierung zu einem
gesundheitsminister und das ist jetzt
einem juli jetzt einen juristisch
gesehen liegt kein zustand die man auf
dauer fortführen kann aber den hätte man
gut und sie haben es angesprochen
noch bis märz so beibehalten können und
die situation ist aktuell keine oder
eine wo es also aufhorchen lässt das
dass abgeordnete sagen wir haben jetzt
diese epidemische lage der nationaler
tragweite nicht mehr das ist durchaus
erstaunlich was ich aber ganz klar
machen will ist rein praktisch wird es
weitere massnahmen geben und die länder
können können sehr viele regelungen und
also meines erachtens aber dann müssen
sie mich korrigieren die die wirklich
relevanten also in der praxis relevanten
weiterhin fortführen
ja ich glaube sie sind angesprochen
herrscht immer
genau dem dem kann ich natürlich
zustimmen mir war es halt wichtig ich
habe wie gesagt die diskussion nicht
verstanden weil ich glaube das ist ein
falsches signal gewesen aber ich bin
wirklich ich hoffe das ist die die
länder in einvernehmen mit dem bund vom
gelingt hier eine rechtssicherheit
wirklich zu generieren die uns eben all
diese maßnahmen die wir wissen dass sie
wirklich wichtig sind und funktionieren
dass die fortgeführt werden können ich
glaube da sind uns auch einig das muss
sein ich habe so ein bisschen die angst
und befürchtungen dass der
flickenteppich wieder wieder stärker
wird wenn das jetzt wieder komplett in
länder hand gegeben wird weil das virus
ist in bayern und in sachsen genau das
gleiche wie in schleswig-holstein
nordrhein-westfalen oder auch hier im
schönen hessen insofern macht es da für
mich eigentlich keinen unterschied wie
ich reagiere ich muss im prinzip
eigentlich auf meine zahlen reagieren
und das kann ich auch mit
bundeseinheitlichen vorgaben insofern
habe ich so ein bisschen die befürchtung
dass wir wieder in einen ziemlichen
fleckenteppich abrutschen wobei den
haben wir ja eigentlich schon ja da
kommen wir gleich auch noch die republik
noch und da genau genau weil sie gerade
gesagt haben dann haben wir ja
eigentlich schon und nicht nur
eigentlich genau den haben wir also
ändert sich an diesem flickenteppich der
immer besprochen wird da nichts weil
weil auch aktuell ist es so geregelt das
ist zwar also bundesweit möglichkeiten
gibt was daraus jedes land macht ist ist
die sache von jedem land schon jetzt nur
es gibt in zukunft weniger möglichkeiten
das heißt den flickenteppich den wir
haben den werden wir beibehalten
er sieht nun nicht mehr ganz so bunt aus
weil nicht mehr alle maßnahmen möglich
sind da reden wir gleich noch intensiver
drüber da wollen wir nämlich auch gerade
noch mal auf einen beitrag schauen den x
vorbereitet haben also die maßnahmen die
gegen korona ergriffen werden die sind
eben von bundesland zu bundesland
verschieden drei bundesländer die mit
ihren regelungen besonders streng sind
die wollen wir jetzt noch mal zeigen
in sachsen gilt ab heute in vielen
bereichen die zweijährige das heißt nur
noch geimpfte und genießen dürfen etwa
in restaurants clubs und zu
großveranstaltungen
außerdem gilt eine ffp zwei masken
pflicht im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und in taxis
ungeimpfte mitarbeiter in pflege- und
altenheim müssen sich täglich testen und
treffen darf man sich nur mit maximal
zehn menschen es sei denn man ist
geimpft genießen oder unter 16 jahren ab
dienstag gelten auch in bayern
verschärfte regeln und zwar 2 g statt 3g
ausgenommen sind gastronomie körpernah
dienstleistung und
beherbergungsunternehmen hier gilt 3g
plus ungeimpfte haben mit einem pcr-test
zutritt auch die masken pflicht wurde
verschärft in baden württemberg geht das
gesundheitsministerium davon aus dass
schon ende der woche die alarmstufe gilt
dann gilt zweig bei vielen öffentlichen
veranstaltungen in der innen gastronomie
und auf weihnachtsmärkten
zusätzlich dazu werden kontakt
beschränkungen für ungeimpfte verschärft
ein haushalt darf sich dann nur noch mit
einer weiteren person treffen
ausgenommen davon genesene geimpfte und
kinder
so da haben wir jetzt einige punkte
gesehen über vieles haben wir schon
gesprochen kontakt beschränkungen waren
wir jetzt noch aufgefallen was hält der
mediziner fragen wir gleich was hält die
juristin davon hat es vorhin gesagt okay
das wird dann in der kommenden wenn es
so kommt dann tatsächlich was ampel
partei und die nerven nicht mehr drin
sagen genau wir haben den
gesetzesvorschlag hier liegen wenn er
jetzt so beschlossen wird kann immer
noch dran gedreht wird aber wenn er so
beschlossen wird ist genau das raus dann
ist das was gerade also aktuell realität
ist in manchen bundesländern nicht mehr
möglich sind die rechtlich so halte die
kontakte schenkung weil sie dann auch
wieder unverhältnismäßig sind ist ein
extrem tief greifender einen eingriff
der kann gerechtfertigt sein also dass
das alles dass das kann alles
verhältnismäßig sein es ist mehr ein
politischer wille der hier gerade zum
ausdruck kommt weil ich nehme an das ist
die fdp inzwischen fdp grünen und spd
zumindest einigkeit besteht dass man die
ganz tief greifenden maßnahmen raus
nehmen will da beruft man sich aufs
grundgesetz ich würde sagen es ist vor
allem politischer wille widerspricht
natürlich dann dem liberalen grund credo
vielleicht noch mal die frage auch an
den mediziner kontakt beschränkungen ein
sinnvolles instrument
ja streng genommen das beste aber wie
verbreitet sich das virus über die
kontakte und wenn ich die kontakte
reduziere weise auf ein minimum
reduzieren das haben wir ja in den lock
downs gesehen dann habe ich die chance
das infektionsgeschehen wieder in den
griff zu bekommen ich denke auch dass es
politisch nicht mehr gewollt ist eben
diese tiefen einschnitt zu machen also
es ist unsere aufgabe jetzt zu wege zu
finden
die kontakte die wir erlauben sicherer
zu machen und da gehört eben das testen
dazu und ich bin der meinung dass wir
wenn wir uns nur auf zweig verlassen
dass wir da auch wieder einen fehler
machen ich denke regelmäßige testungen
einer bestimmten situationen auch
geimpft und genesen ist absolut
notwendig um hier wieder ein bisschen
dampf vom kessel zu nehmen das
infektionsgeschehen wieder besser
kontrollieren zu können der rechtliche
flickenteppich sache ist auch
angesprochen worden wird oft beklagt ist
dagegen eigentlich irgendwas zu machen
andererseits ich meine wir leben in
einem föderalen system und es kann ja
auch vorteile haben also auf regionale
unterschiede auch dann entsprechend
unterschiedlich reagieren zu können also
wir hatten schon eine andere situation
die bundes notbremse wurde um die
ostertage gezogen und da gab es
bundeseinheitliche regelung ich muss
sagen also ganz privat gesagt ich fand
das gut als bürgerin ich war da noch in
elternzeit ich hab das nicht juristisch
begleitet sondern habe das einmal erlebt
und fand es ganz schön mich an den
instanzen zu orientieren ich wusste was
grundsätzlich bundeseinheitlich gilt und
und wenn bei mir ich wohne in frankfurt
die zahlen hoch gegangen sind dann
wurden kitas geschlossen oder was auch
immer gerade dann erforderlich war damit
konnte ich umgehen da konnte ich mich
orientiert der einheitlichkeit mit mit
der einheitlichkeit ist finde ich bin
ehrlich gesagt großer verein hat von von
einheitlichkeit er ob das ganze
verfassungsrechtlich zulässig war das
erfahren wer so in eins zwei drei wochen
denn bis ende november hat das
verfassungsgericht versprochen gibt es
die erste hauptsache entscheidung vom
verfassungsgericht zur bundes notbremse
das heißt da warten wir auf eine
entscheidung steht auf dem prüfstand
weil dass es wiederum jetzt juristisch
gesehen der nachteil an so einem
bundesgesetz ist ein gesetz und die
eigenen einzige möglichkeit mich als
bürger dagegen zu wehren gegen zu
maßnahmen ist der gang zum
verfassungsgericht und der dauert ein
bisschen das heißt die ganzen verordnung
die es gibt mir die mich die mich in
meinem alltag da kann ich überall zum
verwaltungsgericht vor ort gehen ja da
ist er der juristische weg ein bisschen
kürzer bei einem bundesgesetz gibt geht
nur der gang zum verfassungsgericht der
den haben sind viele gegangen
ja wobei ehrlich gesagt von ostern bis
jetzt also deren das schon gearbeitet
würde sagen die dringlichkeit ist ja
auch durchaus gegeben wir haben ein paar
allgemeine fragen auch an den virologen
und
zwar wann werden wir diese pandemie
endlich los fragt ihn youtube es ist
wahrscheinlich 100.000 dollar frage ist
ständig von einer emmy die rede werden
wir uns womöglich in diesem dauerkrisen
zustand auf jahre befinden das ist
natürlich eine befürchtung die viele
menschen gerade so ein bisschen haben
können sie diese befürchtungen
zerstreuen
also erstens werden wir in deutschland
und weltweit wenn wir mit dem virus
weiterhin leben müssen es wird egal wie
wir es anstellen es wird so schnell
nicht verschwinden aber wenn ich bin der
meinung wenn wir den impfstoff für alle
haben also wenn jeder von uns also auch
unsere kinder und unsere kleinstkinder
wir in der lage sind diese aktiv zu
schützen von denen die sich ihm einfach
nicht impfen wollen damit muss an der
gesellschaft in irgendeiner form auch
zurechtkommen dann ist es meiner meinung
nach wirklich auch gerechtfertigt in die
normalität zurückzukehren weil ich mit
bin auch kein freund davon diese vision
weiter zu spinnen dass wir uns auf ewig
und drei tage immer wieder mit masken
mit abstands diskussion mit 3g 2g usw
auseinandersetzen müssen wir müssen
irgendwann zur normalität zurück für
mich ist das denn eben erreicht wenn
sich alle impfen lassen können weil er
als jeder in der hand sich zu
entscheiden und wenn das dann genug gibt
dann werden auch die impf durchbrüche in
der form nicht mehr relevant sein und
auch hier geht ja die entwicklung weiter
die impfstoffe die wir jetzt haben ist
die erste generation an impfstoffen die
wehren weiterentwickelt an varianten
angepasst die abstände können optimiert
werden die die die man brauche ich eine
booster impfung das ist alles noch viel
viel luft nach oben und deswegen denke
ich dass wir im nächsten jahr über die
rückkehr zur normalität sicherlich
diskutieren werden und wahrscheinlich
dass die booster impfung ansprechen also
vielleicht da gerade auch nochmal ihre
einschätzung was ist wichtiger jetzt
boostern vor allem oder doch irgendwie
schauen dass man die leute die noch
keine erstimpfung haben dazu bewegt sich
noch impfen zu lassen
oder beides ist gleich wichtig definitiv
beides genau genau definitiv beides
haben es ist wichtig jetzt die ältere
bevölkerung die box risiko haben weil
sie recht früh in diesem jahr schon
geimpft worden sind dass die jetzt
wieder durchbrüche bekommen die sie
intensiv pflichtig macht oder gar
sterben lässt da müssen wir rein mit der
booster impfung um diese gruppe
definitiv abzusichern für den herbst und
winter gegebenfalls je nachdem was die
ständige impfkommission jetzt mit den
aktuellen forschungsdaten macht auch
eine breitere booster impfung um
insgesamt etwas mehr die impf
durchbrüche zu reduzieren aber wir
müssen ganz klar eben auch noch
diejenigen die nicht hardliner sind aber
unentschlossen sind in den immer noch
infektions
informationsdefizite haben die müssen
wir versuchen zu erreichen und da ganz
gezielt hinarbeiten also zweigleisig
auch hier leute mit infektions defizite
haben wir endlich ganz klar aber
information in der tat es ist ja auch
unser geschäft da wollen wir natürlich
gucken dass wir die leute gut versorgen
so rienäcker hat über youtube schreibt
wie realistisch ist denn ein neuer
kompletter locker und ich glaube den
will wirklich kein mensch kann man das
ausschließen nie ausschließen also das
ist deswegen deswegen gibt es diese
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
die die vorgesehen ist und wenn ich weiß
nicht welche zahlen ist braucht aber
wenn die wenn die lage so ist dass sie
dramatisch ist und wieder anders
reagiert werden muss dann der bundestag
zusammen und und dann werden all diese
maßnahmen wieder möglich oder aber es
gibt eine bundes notbremse
20 22 dezember 20 also all das ist
möglich also maßnahmen können ergriffen
werden auch schnell das haben wir ein
crooner gelernt ok also wie gesagt das
will keiner wäre dann vielleicht noch
mal verbunden mit dem appell sich
vernünftig zu verhalten vielleicht noch
mal das schlusswort an den mediziner ja
machen sonst vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen mut wie gut sind wir denn
aufgestellt für den winter glauben sie
es wird zumal obwohl es ein bisschen
ruckelt im moment dann doch irgendwie
gut werden oder mit welchem gefühl gehen
sie so ins nächste halbe jahr
also ich bin im blick ein bisschen ein
bisschen skeptisch ich sehe auch
tagtäglich in der in der test routine
was was die zahlen hergeben wir fahren
pcr-test hoch ohne ende die positiven
quote ist ist teilweise je nachdem
welche zentren nicht mehr anschauen weil
bei 50 prozent der gäste positiv also
uns steht jetzt erst mal eine ziemlich
harte zeit bevor und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob wirklich bringt die maßnahmen
in der form so konsequent umgesetzt
werden dass wir jetzt überall auf die
schnelle die pandemie brechen könnte ich
mache mir ein bisschen sorgen was ist
dass viele veranstaltungen angeht das
prinzip auch gerade ich weiß jetzt bin
ich wieder die spaßbremse das
weihnachtsmarkt und so so freizügig zum
teil gestaltet werden könnte also da
muss man eigentlich noch mal richtig den
fuß vom gas nehmen damit wir
einigermaßen vernünftig durch den winter
kommen auch hier wir haben es immer noch
in der hand es ist möglich wir sollten
aber zu sehen dass wir wirklich die
geeigneten maßnahmen jetzt möglichst
schnell auch umsetzen ja vielen dank
nochmal für diese einschätzung
spaßbremse ja gut das ist natürlich auch
ein bisschen ihre rolle in diesem ganzen
zusammenhang wir sind trotzdem sehr froh
dass wir sie heute abend da hatten und
dass wir uns nochmal so kenntnisreich
die ganzen dinge einordnen konnten
vielen dank noch mal an martin stürmer
vielen dank natürlich auch nochmal an
sarah tacke für die ganzen rechtlichen
einordnung die leiterin unserer
redaktion recht und justiz ihr im zdf
dankeschön danke auch bei euch liebe
userinnen und user für das mitmachen für
zahlreiche einreichen euro fragen und
kommentare soweit unser thema für heute
wir wünschen euch einen schönen abend
und sagen bis demnächst